[Musique] a
toujours aimé Noël, mais en tant que maman,
c'est beaucoup de travail entre l'emballage,
les courses, la cuisine et la décoration
[Musique]
il n'y a presque pas de temps pour en
profiter et une seule chose, oh non, qu'est-ce que ça
pourrait rendre encore plus  stressant ma
mère vient pour Noël
tout ira bien
elle est l'être humain le plus critique de
la planète je ne peux pas arranger ça pas Beyonce
je suis ici pour voir ma fille à Pâques
Noël Noël nous ne pouvons pas attendre
chaque minute avec toi
oh  non où est ton arbre je comprends
bien clairement pas à la gym regarde je suis une
femme de 34 ans et elle
me dit toujours comment vivre ma vie je suis à la maison
j'ai les cheveux un peu colorés exactement
comme je l'ai dit nous ne le faisons pas  j'aime utiliser le
mot normal tu allais être mon meilleur
ami pour toujours Je veux organiser une
fête de Noël où est ma maison oui
et cent quatre-vingt-quatre personnes
viennent combien cela coûte
pouvez-vous mettre un prix sur merveille en
fait  Cygne glace joie Noël
ce y  oreille tu es une maman maman Pierre et joie
ils donnent de la joie elle va continuer à te traiter
comme ça jusqu'à ce que tu la combattes
physiquement je ne vois pas Noël revenir
des décorations parfaites alors quoi de parfait
mettons le cul mais je peux
Noël qui n'a pas fait  sortez exactement
comme je l'avais prévu mais vous les gars allez
je ne sais pas pense que je suis si dur avec
elle mais j'avais une mère horrible elle m'a une fois
giflé pour avoir porté des chaussures à bout ouvert
sur un voilier qui était une autre heure
que  c'était il y a deux mois
sanim numéro deux comment vous êtes-vous rencontrés Oh
cirer cette affaire oh mon dieu ça ressemble
à un agent de stationnement à chaque fois je pense que
je suis le plus bizarre dans ce groupe tu ouvres
la bouche nous sommes allés au bal ensemble Oh
et puis je suis comme si j'allais bien
[Musique]